everyone
this meeting is a special meeting and it
to look at the greater Manchester fire
and rescue service
Fire cover review that they've had and
there's a public Council consultation
with regard to that
review and I'd like to welcome all our
guests from the fire service
pleased to actually see you all
um some familiar faces as well
and thank you to the members who have
come along tonight as well and we've got
a few members that are not on the
committee but have got a real interest
in the
um the discussion that we're going to
have tonight
um so
the way that I want to really structure
this meeting is that
um
that if we take the fire service
present presentation first and then we
can ask questions as members to that and
then following that I think we've got
the uh the fbu who are coming along and
they will present to it as well and in
the same way we can question that and I
think at the end of that the committee
members of scrutiny will stay behind and
everyone else will go and we will
determine what what we feel is the
outcome and what we can actually
recommend to the executive and leader
okay with that I think it's over to you
we'll move away so everybody can see the
screen
so
um thank you chair for the opportunity
to attend scrutiny me committee meeting
this evening my name is Dave Russell I'm
the Chief Fire officer and I'm joined by
my colleague Carlos meakin who's the
director of Service delivery
and we've just got
um a small number of slides to run
through and what I respectfully ask is
that you allow us just to run through
the slides and then we can take
questions at the
and I'm going to set the service context
and then Carlos is going to talk
specifically around the local context in
relation to both Trafford and sale and
the implications of our proposal but
just by way of a recap the fire cup of
review is something which we do every
four years
and the purpose of the review is to
ensure our resources are used in the
most efficient and
effective way
so it involves a review of all of our 41
fire stations
it looks a incident activity levels on
those fire stations and the review
challenges as to consider as it says
there have we got
the resource is being used in the most
optimal way the outcome of the review so
this is my professional um
view I've presented the fire couple
review to
um the deputy mayor and I strongly
believe that the review is the best way
for us to build a stronger and more
resilient greater Manchester fire and
rescue service
and also it is the right balance of
change for gain without creating undo
um risk so just to put that into context
there's no new money coming into the
service
nor is there any money being taken out
of the service what the review is about
trying to recalibrate our our resources
and in doing so
um create an additionality which I'll
talk about in a minute in terms of
resources we've got within the service
um what um I do recognize is that any
change
to our existing Fire cover as it stands
currently
um has an impact on performance
a service for a station and Ward level
and of course the change in terms of
response times these most pronounced
Ward level and of of course the impact
will reduce as you look at that
at a service level and the only way to
avoid that is to adopt a position of
um no change and
um again my professional view is is a no
change Fire cover review whilst it may
have been a safe and easy option for me
to present as the Chief Fire officer I
do believe
um it would have been the wrong thing
for the service and importantly
um the people of Greater Manchester and
when I say that people are greater
Manchester I say that in the context
that we're providing a fire and rescue
service across the 10 boroughs
to whatwards of 2.8 million people and
what we do know is is that risk is
variable it's Dynamic it does move which
is really the Cornerstone of the
proposals within the Fire cover review
just in terms of practical terms so when
I say
um more prevention and more protection a
more resilient emergency response
service the outcome of the Fire cover
review with the proposals
um are approved and I'm conscious that
we are still
um out to public consultation until the
24th of
um July but more prevention and
protection so an outturn of the fire
coffee review
is the ability to reinvest 340 000 pound
into prevention and protection
um services so these are members of
staff that are not conditioned to ride
in the five Appliance the dedicated
members of staff that work within
communities in both the prevention and
the protection
setting
a more resilient emergency response
service a greater Manchester level on
the basis it allows us to move from the
50 to a 52 pump
um whole time Fleet
and the final point there around two new
enhanced rescue stations
um that's at Lee and Ashton
alongside an opportunity to uplift the
capacity and capability of our special
appliances so all of that is delivered
within the existing
um budget and I'm sure as members of the
um Council you'll recognize that
um often decisions need to be taken in
terms of where you deploy your resources
so there's no resource
coming out of the organization the
resources being distributed differently
under these
um proposals and Carlos will talk about
that in a little bit more
um detail this is the only slide that
I'm going to share in terms of times but
I am
um conscious that understandably members
will want to take us there in more
detail in terms of questions
[Music]
um just to be clear myself and Carlos
attended a public meeting in Partington
um last Friday
um very happy to talk about Partington
and the challenge that that and presents
but those are the average response times
um at both a Trafford and at a sale
station level and they accept they are
average so in some equations they may be
quicker some applications they may be
there may be longer but
sorry calculating the average response
time is how we we measure our
um performance so
at that point there I'll pass over to
Carlos
thanks Chief
um so in terms of the proposals
um specifically for sale and offerton
we're proposing that the station turns
to what we term at a day crewing station
um so this is a a duty system which is
uh successful at six other stations
across greater Manchester and it's what
we're proposing for sale and offering
and we'll get into the the rationale for
that um later in the presentation or
indeed in the questions so what would
that mean in terms of a change so if
it's agreed then the proposals are
implemented and the response the
response from firefighters at the
station during the day will be exactly
the same as it is today so that's
between the hours of half eight in the
morning and six o'clock in the evening
Monday to Friday and half eight in the
morning one o'clock in the afternoon
Saturdays and Sunday the rest of that
time
um firefighters would um respond to
station within an on-call Arrangement
um and would be required to base
themselves within a four minute response
boundary
so as I've said this isn't a brand new
system to the service he's tried and
tested and he's working successfully at
six other stations and you can see that
the list of stations that it's operating
at there and the system itself
um so the system that we've got in place
at the moment requires 28 staff across
four watches to operate
um an SDS system as it's termed the day
crowing system requires 13 staff on a
self-rostering basis so um by
implementing that system and would
create some um Financial efficiencies in
terms of the resources and we can
redeploy firefighters to other areas of
the service and which is why we can
reconfigure the service in the way we're
proposing and realize that growth
so when we're choosing which stations to
propose to change to a do a day crewing
model we look at um a number of
different aspects so the volume of
incidents in terms of the demand
operationally on that station
the level of risk across the affected
area so we have a methodology in terms
of how we stratify risk from fire and
the impacts on performance following
proposed changes and that speaks to our
workload modeling and the analysis that
we undertake
um within that software so that
basically looks back at the incidents
that we've had over a three-year period
we build into the system some changes at
certain stations and then the the
modeling software tells us what the
anticipated impact of that will be
we also look at the coverage from
surrounding stations and I'm sure we'll
get into this in more detail
um later on but that is an important
aspect in terms of the number of fire
engines that can cover any particular
area within a 10 minute response time
and so that's another Factor that's
considered and then because the the duty
system that we're proposing specifically
affects the nighttime coverage we do
focus on nighttime incidents during the
hours
um when the Fire cover is proposed to be
changed and that looks at both volume of
incidents and again types of incidents
during that period
and so why have we
um developed proposals for for sale so
during the last three years for sale
when we've looked at the the incidents
the total incidents at night time so
those hours that we've talked about I've
totaled 898 Which is less than one a day
and is the third lowest of all our
current whole time stations
so of the 35 that I currently hold time
and nighttime life risk incidents which
are the most critical incidents for us
um there's been 146 in that three-year
period so less than one and life risk
incident per week and again that's the
third lowest of all whole time stations
and then we look at the risk so there's
a balance between the demand and the
risk and we we're not saying that there
won't be any risk whatsoever
um we recognize that will always be an
element of of risk across any area but
in terms of the percentage of the the
station area that we determined to be
very high risk
um 2.6 of of the total area is is
classified as very high risk which is
the fourth lowest of all whole time
stations and so when you look at the
other stations
um which are lower than that they are
like point of a percent so it is there's
not a lot between those other stations
so when we we look at all those
different parameters and we also have
existing day cruise stations which have
greater numbers of either incidents and
or high risk areas than sale has so
again those those six stations are
operating effectively and so we look at
how how they're operating in the context
of their risk and demand when proposing
that against new stations and as I've
said there's coverage from three other
stations within 10 minutes into
um sale which is more than five out of
the six existing day crude stations
so
um there have been a number of questions
in terms of what will this proposal mean
for staff if indeed it does go ahead
so importantly the proposals will not
result in any redundancies or job losses
so as we've said we will look to
redeploy staff to either other stations
or other parts of the service whether
that's in prevention and protection
functions
it's an extremely family friendly uh
system as it allows staff to more freely
choose their their shifts when they're
working so in essence it's a
self-rostering system So currently today
um the station operates a two two four
so two days two nights followed by four
days away from station and that is just
a role in pattern whereas
um with the self rostering system that
we're proposing staff are able within a
range of minimum and maximum number of
shifts within a reference period to pick
and choose which shifts they want to
work which fits around their personal
circumstances
there's an attractive
remuneration package so and staff will
have a 17.5 uplift on pay to operate
this self-rostering system
um and provide that cover throughout the
evening
and it also attracts a housing and
lighting allowance
um so there is a financial package
wrapped around this as well
um we recognize that both the stations
proposed there'll be staff who who may
not want to work this system and and
we've committed to staff that we will
work with them to identify their top
three choices in terms of other stations
where they wish to work
um and they will take priority over any
other transfer requests promotions or
new starters into those stations so they
will get absolute top priority if they
decide they want to move away from the
station and we'll continue to work with
staff in terms of their personal
circumstances and when we get get to a
point and if we get to a point where
we're moving to a transition plan
individual personal circumstances will
be taken into account and we'll try and
work with stuff as much as possible to
smooth out
um that transition to a new station or a
new role
um in terms of
um the other proposals as the Chiefs
already touched on which we're trying to
build a stronger more resilient gmfrs to
to address the risk that we Face across
greater Manchester so we want to
um introduce two new fire engines into
Manchester Borough which will take the
fleet from 50 to 52 fire engines using
our analysis again looking at demand and
risk in the community we're proposing
that those fire engines will be located
at Manchester Central and Moss side
so proposals are about ensuring
resources are in the right place at the
right time based on our assessment of
risk across greater Manchester and
there's a number of assets to that as
I've already touched on
um the two new fire engines will
contribute to reducing attendance times
inside and outside of the m60s it says
and I think it's important to stress
that whilst these additional fire
engines may be located in Manchester as
a Borough the outer greater
manchester-wide asset and recently and I
think this is important in terms of how
you view fire cover the not fixed
resources in a fixed geography it's a
system and the the resources are
continuously moving about managed
dynamically within office Fire Control
they always mobilize the quickest or
nearest resource and as we've seen
recently with floods you know an
incident that we had in sale area a
couple of weeks ago it was attended by a
fire engine from Stockport Borough
because the fire engine from that
locality was already tied up at another
incident in the area
um so as I said the the resources may be
located in Manchester but they will
provide cover across the whole of
Greater Manchester as do all of the
resources that we've got operating today
um I think the final point there just in
terms of business continuity when we go
into what we call State conditions so
when we've got um a high number of calls
in a short period of time
um having 52 fire engines is clearly
better than having 50 and gives us that
additional resilience so we we can
um call upon neighboring Farm Rescue
Services if we need to
um but it's much better for us as a
service to have an additional um two
pumps in the fleet
so when we're talking about building a
more resilient
um fire and rescue service for greater
Manchester I think one of the points
that we we emphasize is around the
high-rise building stock in Greater
Manchester now clearly for anybody who's
been anywhere near the city center
you'll you'll note the the ever-changing
skyline and and every week There's new
towers going up not just in the city
center but in the surrounding areas as
well
I think just to emphasize the point
around high-rise buildings our
predetermined attendance so that's the
minimum number of fire engines that we
will send to a high-rise
um fire
uh requires five fire appliances in the
first response and that's compared with
three for for a residential property
as it says there there's currently 30
high-rise buildings being completed
every year in Manchester Borough alone
in 2017 they were just short 500
high-rise buildings in Greater
Manchester the numbers set to rise from
620 this year to over 920 35 so again
whilst
we are having a backward look in terms
of our analysis in terms of what
incidents we've had and our attendance
times we're also looking forward trying
to adjust future risk which is a
statutory Duty placed upon us a service
thanks Carl so really it just brings me
back to the slide but we um started with
so the reviews predicated around
ensuring the resources are used in the
most efficient and effective way
um the changes we are Consulting on at a
GM level is about building a stronger
and more resilient
Grace of Manchester fire and rescue
service and we do believe that it's the
right balance of change for gain without
creating
um on June risk thank you chair
thanks
thank you for the presentation
um I'll I'll open the discussion up with
the members
um
there's three members there just
I'll just put you in order of what and
when hand went up
um
yes
all right
[Music]
we we have had representations from Ward
councilors
um which obviously we have to take
notice of of that
um and
um
nothing
basically we want to get as many views
as we possibly can and we do have
um other than the committee we do have
um Ward members from the most affected
area and I'll actually bring those in
um first if that's okay with any with
our members on this committee
um right so
um
Ben we wanted to speak
thank you chair and um thank you very
much to officers from the fire service
for coming to speak to the committee
um I'm a council professional mersey
water where sale fire station is located
uh I'm also the low parties
parliamentary candidate for Ultraman
sail west so I represent and aspire to
represent some of the residents most
affected by the proposals in relation to
sale fire station uh I should say that I
attended a public meeting in sale and
there was a lot of
um Anger from residents at that meeting
I don't think that's a a
misrepresentation in any way I've had
contact from a lot of residents about
this I think over a you know a short
space of time this is probably the most
uh this is probably generated the most
number of
um concerns complaints from residents
over that period of time
I've also met with the fbu and
firefighters that sell fire station and
grateful also that I was able to meet
with the deputy mayor and the Chief Fire
officer last week to discuss some of the
concerns that I have about these
proposals
I had some concerns about the extent of
the consultation but I'm pleased that
the fire service have responded to that
and extended the consultation period and
also arrange the event in uh Partington
that was referred to so I'll just if I
may share just focus on my remaining
concerns really about the proposal
as it affects sale fire station and and
sell residents in in my eyes
I should just say the rationale behind
the review makes perfect sense I accept
that I accept that the service need to
review how their resources are deployed
and respond to changing risk around the
greater Manchester area
um and I think it's a difficult one
because no resident no resident is going
to be happy being told that they will
have to wait longer for a fire engine if
their house is on fire
um so you're never going to get public
that are completely happy with any
proposal like that but I think the
question for me and if I may say the
question for the committee is
is whether that delay is acceptable and
and what that actually represents and
means to people and I'm afraid that
based on the information we have so far
I don't think there's enough Assurance
from me or for residents as to what
these changes would actually mean I know
there's been reference to an average
delay of one minute 10 seconds
um there's also been an isochrome
produced which supposedly shows a four
minute drive time for firefighters I
think that's completely discredited if I
may say so
um anyone who's seen it will know that
there's not a chance that you would
drive to sell fire station within four
minutes from some parts of that
isochrone
I know the four minute
um
four minutes standard is is a National
Standard if you like
um and I recognize that this is this is
a proposal so the fire servers are not
going to have actual data on what that
means for sale fire station
I know that there is data for these six
fire stations where day crewing is is
used
um but uh I haven't seen that data
I don't think the public have seen that
data I don't let the committee have seen
it plus sale is a very different
location to the L6 fire stations you
know places like Marple uh little bro
horwich they're all edge of conurbation
locations that serve rural areas sail as
the committee will know is a busy suburb
in the middle of a a busy urban area
housing is expensive it's very congested
at various times of the day school run
in the morning rush hour match day
traffic
so I think the public will get more
reassurance if they saw
uh what an actual four-minute drive time
to sell a fire station looks like in the
in in a variety of conditions and that
would be a much smaller area than than
the isochrome and I think what I also be
looking for is
you know what are the calculated
response times based on those actual
Journeys and what are estimated maximum
response times so one minute 10 second
average doesn't sound too bad a four
minute response time
maybe it doesn't sound too bad but what
are the extremes is it is it 20 minutes
sometimes is it 30 minutes that's that's
Vital Information
and I think most importantly
for me it's you know what difference
does this proposal make to the safety
and the well-being of residents in sale
and residents in Trafford uh more widely
what's the increased risk to people's
property what's the increased risk to
people's lives all I've heard on that is
that um
typically a fire can double in size in
three minutes well a four minute delay
there would be significant but there's
I've heard had no more information
um than that so for me chair
um I've highlighted some of my concerns
and I'll I'll just finish by saying that
you know I'm looking for the reassurance
that
obviously response times will increase
by this proposal but I'm looking for the
reassurance that that doesn't create an
unacceptable risk and
I don't have that reassurance of
confidence at the moment based on the
information that I've seen and that I've
heard this evening I'm afraid
um so I I would urge the committed to
respond to this proposal in a way that
opposes
um that proposal for say a fire station
thank you chair
[Music]
um it may be easier to deal with them
one by one if that's okay
foreign
yeah that's fine so if I could try
um to pick up the questions from
counselor Hartley so I think
um the first one because there were a
number of points in there so if I don't
cover them off please
um bring me back to the ones that I've
missed I think the first one is the
um comment in respect of the isochrome
and the ability for members of staff to
mobilize into the fire station within
um within four minutes I mean Carlos can
speak to the detail in terms of how that
has been calculated but the way we've
calculated it
is consistent with how an isochrome is
calculated for the existing
um Six-Day crude stations but
a couple of points that I would make is
um
there's a recognition that if that
isochrome needs to shrink
in order to deliver a true four minutes
then then it will do so what I am saying
is is the viability
of any day crew fire station whether
it's sale or anywhere else is predicated
on the fact
that staff can consistently mobilize
into the fire station within four
minutes
if the reality is is that that takes
eight minutes it takes 12 minutes then
um
the viability of a day crude Duty system
is a non
um starter so what
um I explained to councilor Hartley when
I met with him and the
um Deputy Mayor so on on every fire call
across all of our 41 fire stations we
measure time to mobilize so if I'm a
um
bottom a workday crude my time to
mobilize into the station under a day
crude model is going to be longer than
someone who works at Manchester Central
fire station who are on this on the
station permanently so we we measure
that
um
and
um what I have said
um and I'm committed to is
um the account of if the proposal goes
um
the responsibility and the
accountability is placed on me as the
chief for delivery in that four minute
um response time whether it's back into
the scrutiny committee or another part
of the council but our performance
against the four minutes is
um ABS is absolute
in terms of the um impact on fire of the
uh delayed response so what I'm not
going to do is sit here and say
um x amount of
um time delayed is acceptable
or or not what we do recognize is that
under this proposal
that fire engine will take longer to
turn out at night time
um now in many respects I carry that
risk now across six other communities in
um in in Greater Manchester
um I accept the point that uh sale is a
more urbanized area than our existing
day crude
um stations
so clearly and the speed of response is
um is um important the times that we've
presented
on average
um over 24 hour period
um 70 seconds isn't it that that was
quoted then that is um
is a delay and I guess context is
everything he's 70 seconds important
um at three o'clock in the morning
turning out to escape fire
probably not is it important in turning
out to a domestic and property fire yes
it is and I think the the one of the key
determinants for rules in
in looking at the viability of a day
crewing Duty system is the amount of
Life risk incidents at that fire station
attends
um by night and have you got the figure
Carlos it's um
yeah
yeah so it was 146 wasn't it 146 life
risk incidents over a three-year
um period um so less than one a week and
I think that's where we've balanced that
on all 40 or 41 of our fire stations in
an Ideal World
we would want firefighters on those fire
stations staffed 24 7. permanent
um response what we believe under the
proposal is given the level of activity
and particularly the number of life
um risk incidents that we do believe
that sale fire station
is conducive to running a day crude
um model
so
Carlos you want to pick up the isocratum
because it is becoming a point of
um contention except to maybe Carlos can
provide a little bit more detail on
thanks Chief yeah in terms of the
isochron I think it's come up at more
sessions so we've
um initially at the requested staff on
station provided an isochrone which is
basically a boundary on the road Network
where
um using the methodology that we have
other stations where we believe staff
can respond within a four minute time
window staff at the stations is fair to
say of strongly
um challenged and the boundary where it
is
now in terms of in terms of determining
where that boundary boundary is we have
probably 10 million data points from our
fire engines every year in terms of uh
rolled speeds so any segment of road is
allocated an average
um speed so some of that does include
um blue light response
but the overwhelming majority is normal
driving
um the reason blue light responses is
included is because
um we've got that data from our fire
engines
um but it's not the overwhelming
majority where we're saying that time is
based on a blue light run
um it is generally average Road speeds
so basically to develop an isochrone and
it's not a perfect science we start from
the station I need to respond to and
work out
um on the role Network in all directions
where four minutes can take us using the
average um Road speed for any particular
section of Road
now clearly for when firefighters are
responding to station they're going the
other way so they're from their home
into the station
but it's really it's really difficult at
this stage to say
um yes you can provide a base then so we
get a specific address but obviously
that's the second part in terms of
implementation should the proposals go
ahead
um and then when we get specific
addresses we'd work that back and say
either yes or no we approve that as a
base location but there is a crown at
this moment in time is provided to give
it um a general sense of where the
boundary would be
as I've said staff have challenged that
but we have committed a number of times
that should the proposals
um move forward into implementation we
will revisit that piece of work and work
with staff to make sure that that
boundary is realistic
um so as I've said until we get specific
addresses to work back from
um it's difficult to to kind of do that
um
completely accurately but the
methodology that we've used is the same
as the other six stations that we've got
and the response from those six stations
and into those stations is effective
I mean just to to add and it's difficult
because in in in some respects um
you know I'm not
um here to try and sell a proposal I
recognize the
um impact at a sale level and I've tried
to provide you a few in terms of trying
to deliver a service at a GM level I
think the one point that's important
here and this is a non-negotiable if we
cannot secure 13 people
within a true four mini boundary of sail
fire station that U.S councilors think
do you know what that is a true four
minutes you've accepted that our staff
look at that and say it's a true four
minutes then the proposal cannot and
won't move
um forward so this isn't about trying to
move to a day query model where on paper
we're presenting a response time of four
minutes when in reality
um that that might be its best day but
more often than not it's response time
is within he's sorry he's greater than
than the um
um four minutes because as I said before
the time to respond is an internal kpi
that needs to be reported into the
deputy mayor as is the case on our other
day crude station so if we're
consistently taking seven eight nine ten
minutes to get into the the fire station
then understandably the question will be
asked
um why so there is a commitment to work
with
um staff
to truly understand
um what that four minutes looks like but
in no way is a service attempt it to be
disingenuous in terms of the isochrome
that it um
um as as put out
clearly though
um four minutes is four minutes
to get to the station
if you've got the firefighters on the
station
you know you're losing four minutes
aren't you
basically
so so that extends the time of to
getting to a fire
quite significantly yeah it does and I'm
and I accept that um
um we operate that system
um today so the delay on those six fire
stations exists today they've been day
crewed stations for many many
um yes I mean IX I accept that the uh
there is a delay
um and in in doing so I guess I'm often
a professional view that that
um delay doesn't present an undue risk
that actually negates the overall gain
in the system as a result of the um
proposals if they are to go through but
you have actually said that
sale is not the same as little bird and
um and Ram's bottom and places like that
so you you you're not comparing like
with light because it is a semi-urban
area whether you like it or not and
um and of course you've also got the
Partington situation which is it's a
long time to get there now
and putting form extra minutes on it
and I'd like to know whether you'd
actually factored in you know the
um the development sort of
you know going to be coming on stream
over the next few years because that you
know brings its own problem yeah uh
could I just ask
Shona you you wanted to
thanks
um thanks Dave
um I mean Ben pretty much covered a lot
of my questions I've just got a couple
um left over
um and I guess I just wanted a bit more
information about the um how
the impact on the um on the firefighters
um of moving to the day crew model I
know you mentioned an uplift
um in salary and I just wondered if
there's 30 is it 13 people who would be
affected by it what what how frequently
they would be required to be available
so I share Ben's concerns about the four
minutes but it's just also the the
impact and the the risk I guess of their
of them not being available
um in those times and it becoming kind
of an unattractive job if you're at work
a certain period of time and then you
have to be available
um the rest and kind of is that 17 and a
half percent uplift to accommodate for
all that available time or are they paid
uh like a minimum level for beat for the
hours that they're available as well
okay
um a few bits to that then so in terms
of how many staff are affected so we're
currently got 28 on the station and
we're moving if proposals go ahead to 13
so it'll be 15 as a minimum who'll be
impacted but we accept that of the 28 at
the station there is a potential that
all 28 don't want to work the system and
like I say will work as closely as we
can with those staff to to relocate them
part of any um transition process in
terms of the 17 and a half percent so
that is
um
in respect of providing on-call cover in
the evening as well so a shift is is a
24-hour shift so there's the hours on
station and then there's the on-call
element in the evening
um and there's a contractual requirement
for a for a minimum number of shifts
within the year and the allowances to
operate the self-rostering system but
also recognizes the additional time that
staff are providing
um on-call outside of a normal shift
time that they would do now so a day
shift on a whole time station SDS is um
half eight till seven
then the firefighters go home
I'll do another day shift and then in
the evening
um evening shifts they'll do seven in
the evening until half eight the next
morning whereas with this a shift will
be I was on station and then the rest in
the 24-hour period on call I think the
reason we reviewed the system and went
to a day crew model because the previous
system was broken so it was a
four day and night solid 96 hour block
of cover which would just be a repeating
pattern so that resulted in real
difficulties in terms of Attraction and
retention to those stations which
compromise the availability of fire
engines but we we undertook a piece of
work
um with fbu colleagues to develop the
day crewing system as it is now
um and as a result in terms of both the
remuneration package and the family
friendly element of the self-rostering
system and the flexibility it provides
we move from a system where every
station was struggling to attract people
to having six stations which are fully
staffed and indeed all six of those
stations have a waiting list of staff to
move into them and so we're confident
that
um we will attract people to the station
but as the Chiefs already said if we
can't attract the minimum of 13 to the
station then the proposals will not move
forward
that helps cover it um I think I just
have um one more uh question
um which I probably should know but I
don't know the answer to 17 and a half
percent sounds fantastic in normal times
but you know we know inflations are
about 10 or 11 at the moment so what
other
um what other pay increases have uh the
the firefighters received this year
foreign
[Music]
pay settlement over uh two years that's
right isn't it
um so that has been negotiated
nationally
um the 17 and a half percent is is on
top of whatever the base pay rate is
um but we recognize that previously
again the system there was a
um a waffle housing allowance which was
allocated to that it was a significant
uplift in the housing allowance and then
we committed within that to uplift that
on an annual basis in line with
inflation so that the cost of housing
for firefighters who are operating this
system is not not fully met we accept
that depending on the area that you're
living in the property that you you're
living in but at least we'll maintain
Pace with the rate of inflation and and
it's a much more uh positive position
than we've had for for any point in time
that I know in the 22 years I've been in
the service
that's great thanks and I guess the only
other point for my colleagues on the
scrutiny committee is I think I'm just
um I find it hard to believe that we can
meet that four minutes knowing the area
as I do and knowing the property prices
in that area that you know I don't think
many of us around this table would be
able to afford on a you know maybe in
our 20s with a starting salary to
purchase a property
um within four minutes in that area and
that's just something that it seems
where it to be to go ahead with
conditions I can't believe that those
conditions would ever be met so there's
a there's a long way to go in terms of
convincing me there but thank you I
appreciate your answers
okay so thanks for that counselor will
Jones
I will come over okay thank you chair um
I'm speaking as a counselor from
Brooklyn's in um in sale I'm councilor
will Jones I've attended several of
these consultation events already this
uh last month or so and it's become
clear to me that mostly when there's
quite a few residents there that felt
quite unsafe about these proposals and
that's understandable we'd expect
residents to not actually accept them
lower standards or lower response times
for their um fire service but two main
things that seem to stand out here as
this form in this response time by um
fire service staff to um get to sailfire
station this
I think is the Crux of why this is
probably unfeasible during evenings it's
going to be almost impossible for any
air fire fire staff to get on get to
sale on the a56 so I think that really
needs to be looked well so however much
you mess around with the road conditions
or the isochrome I don't think you're
ever going to get there with that so
that probably means um you've got big
challenges there and I would also say
the response times are also substantial
ready and sale uh the hired in Trafford
as a whole and they're going to get
higher and I don't think this kind of
offset things based on the data Etc that
you've talked about and that data could
be argued might be a bit unrepresented
because of the covert pandemic and there
might be uh different uh biases in that
um and lastly
um I believe the gain for greater
Manchester as a whole of doing this
reconfiguration and two extra engines
will be a six second response time I
just question is that all really worth
it thanks
councilwin Stanley
foreign
I can't see it
um you also said if plans were to go
ahead there would be engagements to make
sure the four minutes could be met I
think you've done engagement sort of
place before the plans were in place I
think we've been a lot more comfortable
about so because once the plans happen
they will have happened
um I also I know you asked the question
sure but I couldn't remember if I heard
the answer or not
it's to do with the variation in the
response times across Trafford there
were some areas where you're talking
average response time there were some
areas where the response time will will
rise dramatically and I think one of
those areas would be
um in Partington where we're all we've
also there are big plans to build many
more houses out there so I wanted to
make sure that I've been covered in the
plans as well thank you chair yeah and I
think also this coma science in
Parkington as well which you know they
can go up at any time
so it is a worry that it you know
there's going to be time added on from
where we are now and it's you know there
is that danger
um I'll I'll try and get a few more
her questions in and then I'll come back
to you so don't worry Lawrence
I want to thanks chair can I just go
back to the very beginning about the
consultation
um so you're asking scrutiny committee
what they think and you're asking the
residents what they think
what would you feel would be
a positive response from from those
consulties
give you confidence going forward
um
if I understand the um
question correctly I mean it may be
helpful to
um
to share the responses thus far so the
response to the public consultation
is mainly framed from Stockport and
Trafford
so I think it's fair to say the rest of
the other 10 borrowers are fire copy
review is passing
um and people
um but I'm I'm not naive enough to think
that actually if you're advancing a
proposal
that means your fire engine
is going to take longer to attend an
incident by night that the public are
going to think it's a good
um idea
um what
um I I did hope and I still hope is
um as a council and as elected
members you can
um
see what's been tried uh try to achieve
through the um
[Music]
um and Fire cover review but to see it
in a way that I'm describing it you've
you've got a
um
accept that there is a impact
um at a local level in respect of sale
and and somewhere else in Greater
Manchester
um gains so I can understand why
um it isn't
um
um it isn't um seen that that way so I
think in terms of
the response so far it's been
um unsupportive of The Proposal so the
only proposals that are attracting any
comment and or
um discussion is the proposal for sale
and the proposal for
um offerton
um fire station so
um we will capture the public
consultation in the transparency that
we've entered the
um public consultation
um and that will lead me to
um a meeting in the first instance with
the
um Deputy Mayor I think the the points
around the six seconds game and I just
want to come back to the
um isochrome so I'm I'm clear and and at
the moment the
um and your local knowledge will be
better than mine but there isn't there
is an assumption that we cannot
secure 13 people within a true four
minutes of sale fire station
now to be fair you don't know that as
much as I don't know that but what you
what I can't do
in advancing any fire station
um for a day crewing model
is to say listen we'll pick there
because
um
traffic is good
um you know access into the station is
good Etc the the determinants that are
driving sale fire station
um are based upon each level of activity
and each level of risk so we we would
never
ever approach it from the basis of
actually
um let's focus on the four minutes
doesn't care whether they go to 10 life
risk incidents a night we can get people
within within the four minutes so I
think we have got to work back from the
point that the data and professional
judgment has taken us too but if we
cannot secure the 13 people within the
true four minutes that I will be
required to report on
um if the fire station was to go day
crude then as I've said it it is a
non-starter
um the six seconds
it is documented in our
um and Fire cover review and I think it
is a really fair point to say listen
it's that six seconds
worth the the um the overall
um um gain and I think if you look at it
from that perspective
you'd say no it's not
um I think the other
um important
um malignant or the element that I'm
particularly looking at is what it does
give us
it gives us an additional two fire
engines in the city center
24 7. because whether you work in the
city center or you work at sale probably
about six percent of your work in time
you spend attending um operational
incidents and what we do know is
is the rising infrastructure in the city
center and the demands that are placed
on firefighters in terms of gathering
operational risk information
inspecting buildings Etc
it's that area where okay there's a gain
in terms of six seconds but it's that
level of additionality because really
outside of Central London we've probably
got one of the most if not the most
complex City Center built environments
um outside of
um of of of London and I think for me to
deliver these proposals and leave sale
and offerton as they are then then I've
got to find in excess to two and a half
million pound
so for every fire engine that's going in
it's an additional million pound
um the 340 000 Pound That Gets Lost in
Translation in terms of prevention and
Protection work that that is a
significant number of staff that we can
employ to
um
um reduce risk and just finally I'm
sorry if I've not covered all the points
I think it's it's fair for me to just
touch briefly on
um Partington
um I mean it becomes a a circular
conversation I think what was very clear
to myself and Carlos when were you left
Partington is that that Community
um
is concerned and that Community was very
clear that there
um concerns of safety don't go away but
there would be alleviated if you
um maintain sale
um as a 224
um station so I'm not trying to argue
against that we will capture
um that that all what I think I'm trying
to do is to discharge my duties it's the
best I can within a financial envelope
of money that I've got to deliver
um the service and in some respects that
that has caused
um has caused some difficult decisions
to
um be taken but the overwhelming
feedback public feedback or come from
two Borrowers
um and it will be against the um
against the proposals
thanks Dave what I wanted to do was just
talking about that and I I don't envy
you and Carlos um coming to see us
tonight and doing the consultation it
must be very difficult
but I think that that's the Dilemma that
you've got and you've only got a set
budget
and really you're trying to make money
and you're talking about
um introducing two new appliances
basically mentioned on my side you've
got three appliances that are nearly at
the death aren't they they're going to
go down soon and you've got 13 marks
I've read it in here you've got 13 more
that need serious attention
so isn't it that you you we know about
in the town all about juggling the
figures and and trying to spread our
resources but isn't it the case that
really you're trying to
juggle the figures too much and you've
stretched and you're putting yourself in
this difficult position
and those initial reactions from the
people and parties and then some of the
councilors here and other places
that people are really worried about
this and and really it should be going
back and trying to get more resources as
a whole for the service rather than you
know trying to make do with what we've
got that that I think that's the
difficulty that there isn't and people
can see that but I don't absolutely
understand that the pressures that
you're under
yeah and I mean if I can respond and I
mean I'm
um I'm grateful and I'm appreciative for
um I think a recognition of some of the
challenges that
um uh we we face I
am absolutely not trying to
reduce the service
um what I am trying to do is to
reconfigure the service in a way that
allows some growth but to achieve that
in the absence of any new money you've
you've got to accept that actually there
is there is a reduction in this case by
night in the level of service that a
community
um receive I mean you know you only need
to look back 10 years I mean this
service had 66 fire engines
it's lost 16 fire engines over the last
decade let alone the impact in terms of
the reduction in head counts in terms of
staff that work within prevention and
protection so
there are impacts I guess really
um as in all of these sessions where my
understand that I'm never going to be
able to convince anybody or or or or or
or say this is a good idea is he it
comes back to the immediate locality
and of course everybody
um wants their fire station to be crew
24 7.
what I do believe is and this is based
on professional opinion it's what I do
believe is is the model that we've got
on those other six stations accepting
we're moving into a more urban
environment but again nobody knows
whether there's assumptions that this
won't work I genuinely believe
um we we can deliver it and if we can't
for reasons that we've said about the
four minutes
um then um it won't it won't go forward
I I think one of the points is that you
are a greater Manchester fire service
and
if there's a major incident anywhere
all the borrowers help each other you
know and that actually works and it
works well
and
to
have this minor change is disrupting
really a lot of what you already do
which is good work across the whole
of Greater Manchester and everybody
helps each other and I don't think there
is a need because if if there was a
major fire in Manchester and you needed
you know more uh engines you get them
from the other
other areas so I don't really see the
need to make which is a fairly minor
change but it means
that one community
is gonna have to wait an extra four
minutes
which is critical quite frankly and and
that's why we find it difficult to to
sort of agree with the proposals anyway
that there are other people and I I want
to try and you know capture as much as I
can
um so
but I don't know which ones yeah okay
thanks Jay
um I just wanted to pick up on the
consultation a bit further as well and
around the use of what I think is is
quite misleading language
um talking about uh additional day crew
stations as opposed to referring to them
as downgrading uh to full-time or
24-hour stations which which may have
been a more
um
a more honest way of presenting this in
a consultation like this you'd want to
see a real effort made to reach all
corners of the community
uh Crossing language barriers and
reaching out to people who are digitally
isolated and so
has there been a meaningful attempt at
that and or is it just online
um it's actually a question I think
um
in in terms of the consultation
prior to going going live we've engaged
with Chief execs
um leaders we've had a number of
sessions briefing The Wider leadership
team within the combined Authority and
we've contacted
um all our our partners out in
localities to to help spread that word
now I I don't think we're going as far
as leafleting through through each door
within the communities
um across greater Manchester but we have
done our best in terms of reaching out
to those leaders in communities to help
spread the word but clearly as a service
we we won't reach everybody just in
terms of terms of our efforts
um so as far as I'm aware there's
particularly with the public events it's
not just been kind of digital we've
taken some written responses in the room
we've captured every single question and
response in those public meetings
um
but I think the majority of the
consultation has been done online but
like I say we've we've gone as far as
we're reasonably can we believe to to
use those leaders within the community
to contact as many people as possible
thank you
thank you uh councilor for us liberal
Democrat timpley North so we've spoken
quite a bit about night time uh but
we're looking earlier at Great
Manchester fire service website day
crewing often means losing a proportion
of station-based cover at weekends as
well so great if I am Graham Manchester
fire service website says on Saturdays
and Sundays once all station-based
Duties are complete crews could
typically be based at home from one
o'clock onwards so I think we talked a
lot about the sort of theoretical
numbers but it can sometimes be useful
to base that in areas that our residents
understand
so I don't know so United are playing
Old Trafford at a weekend or an evening
in fact as we know Manchester road is
completely impassable with traffic if a
call goes out on a Saturday afternoon
at the moment the crews struggle to meet
the response times when trying to get
across washway Manchester Chester Road
adding in that additional four minute
response time to get from home to the
station is going to push that up further
I guess so that is if the crew can get
there at all so you know the fires are
going to be bigger more challenging Etc
when the crews get there so I think
it'll be interesting to hear you speak a
little bit more about other times not
just night time
and briefly I don't think we addressed a
point that came up earlier from the
other side could you perhaps talk tell
us a little bit about
where this is being deployed in heavily
built up urban areas with a population
density like sale where there's a
decreeing model as being successfully
deployed as far as I can tell looking at
the models and the slides and the things
this has only been done in very sort of
suburb and Rural more countryside areas
so I'd like a case study
from an urban area thank you
uh I think I think you raised some some
Fair points and you know as I've said
before around the isochron and it's a
point that keeps coming up and again
just to emphasize the point you know we
we won't stand by a response boundary
that that is failing for all the reasons
that the Chiefs outline so it I think
we've got millions of data points from
our fire engines from all all times of
day old days of the week
um but it's very it's very difficult to
to pinpoint a specific time during a
match day and say how long is that going
to take oh all we can do and what we
have done is try to build an isochrome
based on the millions of data points
that we've got from our own fire engines
um but like with any element of our
performance whether it's how long it
takes the staff to turn out to the fire
station how long it takes to travel to
certain areas we analyze each element of
our response review that as a matter of
course and when necessary we'll make
changes to that
um now in terms of your point I was on
station on a weekend
um it's not just station-based
activities it's really when all risk
critical activities have been completed
so they might the crews might be out in
the community I don't know a summer fate
are fitting smoke alarms or anything
anything like that outside of on station
duties but if all that work is completed
staff can respond from home
um after one o'clock in the afternoon
so I suppose the point I'm making is it
other than the data that we've got that
has been modeled into the isochrome and
again we have said that we will review
that um to make sure it is a true four
minute response boundary we can't
pinpoint a particular day a particular
time for a particular event as I said
the data is in the system is not data
that we've manipulated it's just the
data points from our our fire engines
that we that we own
so I think there was a question about
the case study
yeah well I mean if I I can
um
um say that I'll do my best to respond
so I have um
I've worked in the fine rescue service
for 32 years the last three years as a
chief in in Greater Manchester so I
think we accept that giving a local case
study from a GM perspective doesn't
exist for the reasons that you've
um um stated
um that then leaves me to fall back on
um prior knowledge elsewhere within the
sector so when I'll give you two
examples
um Leyland and ormskirk I think you'd
accept that there big
um towns both um within Lancashire
um probably operated on the day career
model since I joined Lang's fire and
rescue service which was in 1991.
um I think what's unique for us is is
the the transition from the existing six
to Salem and offer term we accept that
the population density
um in increases but not necessarily that
the volume and frequency of
um fire
follows
um
um so so I mean they're the two case
studies that that I I could provide I'd
never try and compare and and contrast I
understand the uniqueness and the
complexity
um of um of of Greater Manchester but
um
and that's what I'd offer in response to
that question
thank you and I see this is a really
difficult situation that you're in here
um it does seem like the four minute
response is probably not going to be
possible in sale especially from what
you know Shona was saying about how
you're going to attract people to
to live within those four minutes when
the house prices are so so crazily
expensive as well
um so but I'm also interested why it's
all based on past responses rather than
future responses as well in view of
we've already mentioned that about the
housing developments and the and the
industrial things that are happening in
carriage and there's quite a lot of risk
there and I'm also wondering about other
risks as well that haven't been looked I
don't know if they've been looked at
they probably have things like forest
fires and you know the increased risks
of forest fires and flooding and I can
see that there may be compromise needed
because those future risks are going to
be quite extreme
um as far as the four minutes ago I just
wondered if that has always been
successful in in the sixth um fire
stations they always manage to to do
that that four minutes response where
day crewing is going on and I wondered
what you know if this isn't going to
work what what's going to be the
alternative are there any alternatives
that you're looking at thank you
foreign
so if you take the
um the element around
um wildfires and flooding Etc we are as
part of our special Appliance review
because we've done that same time as a
fire cover review and we're seeking to
invest in our assets to respond to those
type of incidents so we were proposing
to uplift the number of staff that we
train
um to a higher level of water rescue
capability we're looking to bring online
an additional
um powered craft so um a powered bolt to
respond to that and we've also this year
for the first time
um introduce the Wildfire Burns
suppression team
um which is intended recognizing the the
greater risk and likelihood of wildfires
to
um to massively reduce the amount of
time that we spend on those type of
fires so if you go back a few years from
doing saddleworth and Winter Hill
incidents that run into weeks and we're
looking to to reduce that so within our
strategic assessment arrest which is a
document that we Refresh on an annual
basis to answer the first part of your
question and we do do a forward look in
terms of what are all the risks across
greater Manchester
um both now and coming in in future
years that we need to position ourselves
to be able to respond to and the purpose
of not only the firecovery view but the
special Appliance review is to make sure
that we have the capacity and the
capability to be able to respond to that
so I've mentioned an uplifting water
rescue assets and the Wildfire burn
suppression team there's other assets
that we're seeking to invest in to
respond to those
so whilst the analysis that we're
presenting in terms of response times is
a backward look at the incidents that
we've had in the last three years we
also look forward to all of the major
infrastructure developments that are
proposed within greater Manchester as a
whole
um but I think what is important to know
if you go back 15 20 years the number of
residents and the number of households
then
significantly less than where we are
today but we've not seen a corresponding
increase in incidents so incidents have
fallen over the corresponding time and
we accept that they've plateaued to a
level
um but what we're not seeing is for
example a doubling in in dwellings and
residents and a doubling corresponding
an area of fires you know people's
Lifestyles and behavior choices are much
more
um
cognizant of fire risk building
materials of advanced significantly we
have highly engineered buildings you
know fire detection within buildings is
is a lot greater than it has been 20
years ago so
um we have a degree of confidence and
obviously we can't predict the future we
don't know where a fire will occur
tomorrow but looking back at the last
three years and then looking forward in
terms of risks and developments across
greater Manchester we then consider that
an an overlay our professional judgment
in on top of the analysis
um that we've looked into that backward
look to configure the service in the
right way to respond to that risk
yeah just just come back on something so
um
it does seem to me that the you know the
the the risks of fire fire the wildfires
and the flooding are actually hugely
more important risks and possibly the
risks of house fires and I wondered like
you know I know you talked about the
more money going into prevention and and
that's clearly is working from what
you're saying which is which is sounds
very positive
thank you
yeah thank you if you've just come back
on that briefly so so you're right in
terms of fires in in houses and they
have a small percentage of our overall
workload in terms of operational
response but we we try and configure the
service in terms of of all risks so it's
not to
um play down the risk of fire in any
sense but we recognize that our
prevention agenda over the last 10 20
years has been really successful which
we've we can evidence nationally as well
as locally and GM in terms of the
reduction in incidents so you know the
behavior changed through
um the advice that our crews have given
in the community as well as feeding
smoke alarms has gone a long way to
reducing that risk and we see that as a
more long-term sustainable way to
respond to that risk but equally
um we accept and I've said it earlier
today that there will never be no risk
whatsoever and we have to be prepared
for a level of risk that will always be
there and configure the service in the
right way to respond so I did ask about
whether there was any alternative to
this
sorry
um yeah so I think the Chiefs probably
um touched in it already so the
proposals that we've presented are our
professional View
looking at the risk and the demand for
those localities but if I think the
alternative is and it will be from a
number of areas but if we can't find the
staff to operate the system
um or you know if if for whatever reason
we implement the system and we're not
comfortable with how it's operating then
the fallback will be the system that
we've we've got now
it would just depend on the Dynamics at
the time I think that wouldn't save you
the money though would it and that's
what I'm thinking how you're going to
find other ways of getting that money
yeah
many of my quote thank you uh
um many of the questions have been asked
but there's a few things I just want to
check on so you're using data from a
three-year period at least one of those
years was not a normal year we had
covered I I just don't see that data's
being representative of of normal
um I'm I am concerned that you're using
blue lit data I I agree that it might
not be all of the data but it it isn't
it isn't like for like the uh the people
that turn out for you will have to obey
the rules of the road stop at a red
light as they make their way in so
the other thing your cruises five crew
for an engine isn't there
and if one person of that five is
delayed or that have mechanical problems
does that engine go with four or do they
have to wait for the fifth
yeah so I think
just to take those two points as I've
said before there are some elements of
blue light
Road speeds in there but it is a small
proportion overall and like I say it's
not an exact same so those data points
are then looked at
um and reviewed and we have produced a
document which explains how we derive at
the isochrons but again as it just to
re-emphasize the point because it is key
and this does keep coming up the Chiefs
committed to this being a true four
minute response boundary and we won't
stand by it if it if it's failing so I
think
um that that's an important
um
points to know in in terms of the
isochrome sorry I've lost my second just
give me a second question again sorry
the five crew um yeah sorry can you
leave with four if one's stuck or one
can't make the yeah so what apologies so
on a one pump station recruiter five on
a two Pump Station recruiter 4-4 and we
do have a minimum level that we require
for a fire engine to go out the door
which is one officer in charge One
driver and and two ba wearers so that's
breathing apparatus two qualified people
on on the truck so if there's four
people who respond to the fire engine
the fire engine can still go and that is
a decision for the officer in charge to
make in terms of how long do they wait
if at all and but if one of those people
that's delayed is the officer in charge
or the driver
then the fire engine doesn't go but the
staff at the station would then ring
Northwest Fire Control inform office
Fire Control and they would send the
next quickest fire engine
yeah thank you yeah I'm uh Geraldine
Coggins I'm one of the green party
councilors for alteringham and um I just
want to thank you for coming tonight and
obviously you're having to make some
really difficult decisions so so thank
you for for all the work you're doing
um on that I suppose one of my queries
is
I think the savings mentioned are 1.134
million if tomorrow the government said
we were just going to give you that
presumably we wouldn't be making these
changes so presumably really this isn't
about you as a Fire Authority trying to
make our city safer this is really about
you trying to deal with the cuts that
the government is enforcing on on you
um so I suppose that's that's one
question I've got I've I've got four I I
do if you'd like them all together or um
one at a time
yeah
okay so so that that's that's the first
one
um the second one is about the one
minute 10 seconds increase time in sale
um I was wondering is that it's
described as an average is that a median
or a mean so is that the time you're
hitting most of the time
um or is it is a crude crude average and
also I think we did ask earlier what is
the actual range so what are the maximum
response times that we're getting and
what the model suggests the new maximums
will be
um I had a few questions about the four
minute range and one thought is that the
time period you're describing is 6 p.m
to 8 30 a.m I think if we put an extra
hour on either side of that so it went
from 7 P.M to 9 30 a.m you would get a
much wider area you can cover
um secondly I'm wondering about how it's
calculated presumably that's driving so
for example Google Maps suggests at 6 PM
Sainsbury's which is basically across
the road from the fire station is a four
minute drive but it's a three minute
cycle
um so so have you considered for example
providing your staff with electric bikes
or e-scooters that would actually allow
them to cut through the traffic
I see
I see cancer Holdings is worried about
this
they're not this is in order for them to
get to the station I'm not suggesting
they're going to fight the fires on
their electric bikes that's what the
proposal is about four minutes for them
to get from home to the station I'm just
saying there's a way out there to get
there faster has it been considered
um I was wondering if you've any stats
on how many firefighters already live
within the four minute range you've
determined so are we asking 90 of them
to move house are we asking 10 of them
to move house
um and finally I noticed that the
discussion tonight has been nearly all
about fires but when we read your report
of course fires are one part of what you
deal with and I know that all the other
responses are often time critical as
well but I'm just wondering how what
percentage of what you do really in that
area is fires and whether whether it
matters our conversation is mostly about
fires or if the time criticalness is is
the same in in the other contexts thank
you
thank you well um I'll take your first
um question and thank you for your
questions so it was in relation to court
so I think it's important that I'm clear
at that and the proposals are not in
response to a reduction in Government
funding so were the
um review talks about a level of saving
that is the level of saving derived from
that proposal but all of the money is
being reinvested back into
um and back into the service so
um and as I said earlier on I think to
be frank the the the the option of a no
change Fire cover review so so we do
this piece of work everything's in the
right place
um
um I think if I had presented that view
then professionally I'd have been
failing in my leadership of the service
what I have done is put forward
proposals which
um
see a realization of two additional fire
engines
see the realization of 340 000 pound
investment into prevention staff and
they also carry a proposal that is
designed to address along standing
Recruitment and Retention issue on our
technical rescue stations at
um at Lee and um Ashton so there's no
reduction
um it's not a response to
um government courts I think it's
essentially saying
um as a chief you've got that amount of
money to deliver the service for the
next four years is that the best way to
deliver the service or can you make some
subtle changes there's subtle changes in
my view I know the difference of opinion
in the room here
um tonight but the change is can two
more of your fire stations in Greater
Manchester
um say it on a retained model
um by by now level of service by day
um doesn't change accepting the point
the councilor made around Saturday and
um and and Sunday and that's where we've
arrived at that view of balancing that
there is an impact invariably there will
be an impact but actually does does the
system and the totality is a result of
that is it stronger
um
um as a as a result so
um I'll pause that and just pass over to
Carlos on the um
yeah
um so I'll do my best to answer them all
so I think in terms of the average
response time question was was it the
median or the range so for a particular
geography all of the incidents within
that geography
um are added together and then it's
divided by the number of instance which
gives an average response time to that
locality now we we accept that there
will be outliers within that so there'll
be some which are a lot shorter in terms
of response times than what the average
is and there'll be some which are
obviously at the opposite end of the
scale but that that's the approach and
that's consistent with with everything
but again it goes back to unless you
pinpoint a specific locality in terms of
an address
um I mean we can't we could model that
but obviously it's a lot more time
consuming which is why we work on on the
average
presumably you could model it for some
of the worst affected areas like say
Partington address we could find out
what the actual extreme high end would
be there yeah
yeah just to add that was a question
from the MP Andrew Weston at the
Partington
um event what we know is we've attended
216 incidents in Partington over the
last
um three years
um of of which
um 29 were life risk incidents
um so so they're the more serious
um incidents and of the 29 20 of those
occurred during the time that we're
talking about that would be
um impacted on and I did um undertake to
take all of those 216 incidents provide
the time to respond now and what would
that time be because obviously we've got
216 address specific points so we're
just in the process of collating that
information together and we'll send it
through to the MP's office that's great
thanks it'd be great if we could get it
here as well yeah
uh
I'm sorry there's three or four points
I'm not addressed yet if that's all
right
apologies is that okay in terms of the
um changing the start and finish time so
the system as it is at the moment is has
been negotiated with the the rep bodies
and now they agreed shift time so there
are limitations in terms of um
contractual hours so we've with day
crewing stations
within the the average for the week
There's a number of hours which you call
positive hours where staff are on
station a number where staff can uh can
undertake that cover on call and so we'd
have to be mindful of that but
it's not something that we couldn't do
but I think by changing it at one
station we'd have to negotiate with the
the fire brigade Union in terms of the
impact that would have then on the other
six stations which already operate this
system
in terms of you point around staff bikes
as a service we don't dictate how staff
get to station I'm not aware of anybody
who travels interstation on the day crew
model who doesn't use a car but an
electric scooter a bike we don't dictate
what that method of Transport is yeah
but the time the four minutes is
calculated by some method of Transport
so that's what the question is is that
cars and yes yes yeah
uh in terms of the number of staff that
that live in the area so this this may
have changed slightly but as of the
second of May this year we know that 22
of our staff live in the sale area uh in
terms of that that boundary that we've
set
um not all of those will currently work
at sale but we do know that people have
expressed an interest to move into sail
fire station and operate the model that
we're proposing
foreign
in terms of the percentage of incidents
which are fires I think the Chiefs
touched on it
um in terms of Partington but going back
to the incidents for for sale overall
nighttime incidents told for three years
was just under 900
um of those
146 returned life risk incidents the
rest of those will be automatic fire
alarms
um and and lower lower risk you know
secondary fire sole loose rubbish on the
street or in a field wheeler bins grass
Etc so it is a the smaller percentage of
the overall incident volume so hopefully
that answers every Point thanks Joe
you've actually uh answered already one
of the purely operational questions I
had about
at what point do you actually deploy the
fire engine when you're waiting for
people to come in and I think you
answered that quite clearly it does lead
me onto a slightly different question
if you look at where sail fire station
is
there's another one up in Altrincham and
there's at least the one that I
personally refer to as the Kellogg's
fire station
um you know where that is
um if you got a shout
for something in sale
at night
would the deployment process actually
wait for sale to activate or would the
control room activate one of the units
from alteringham or from Stratford
[Music]
thanks for your question I think um it
depends on the nature of of the incident
in so much as
um whatever the predetermined attendance
is so that's the minimum number of fire
engines that we'd send for any
particular incident types or for a
high-rise X5 for a house it's three
um if it was a wheelie bin it it would
be one
and so those numbers are based on
um the tax that are required to set up
an initial safe system of work to allow
firefighters to deploy so that said once
the um the mobilizing system at
Northwest Fire Control receives an
addressable location the system which
automatically knows the status and
location of all of our assets will
propose a number of fire engines to the
control operator
um and whichever is the quickest on
nearest to to the incident the uh
control operator will press the button
and those will be mobilized
automatically so
if sale is the closest and
um and the quickest to get to the
incident and say well we're part of that
predetermined attendance if there's
others that are quicker even though the
fire might be in sales area and then it
will propose them so it it's dynamic in
terms of which ones it selects but I
think it's an important point because
the fire engines aren't always located
on the fire station they're out um doing
activities in the community the training
um other fire engines are within
different areas so Manchester might
already be in in Trafford but the system
as I said recognizes
um the location of every one of our
assets and which one will be quickest to
that location
which is a magic part of that answer
part of the response
we've been concentrating on fires in
sale being serviced from the sale fire
station and what you've just described
is a much wider resource pool to to
respond to any major incident I thank
you for that thanks
thank you chair sorry just to follow up
on cancer Holden's question
it gives you a wider resource pool but
it also gives you a wider number of
incidents that the service is responding
to
um so I think that's an additional
concern there's only one pump in
altering him there's one pump in
Stratford and there's one pump in sale
and they fetch of these proposals will
offensively to go to two and a half
pumps rather than three pumps so I
suppose the question is um
are we actually focusing too narrowly
here in just looking at incidents into
sale because
if you have a house fire in Old Trafford
or Stratford that would probably need
all three pumps to go out from all those
three fire stations thank you
thank you I think I think you raise a an
important point and you know the the
point there about Fire cover being a
system is really pertinent to the
discussion tonight so if there is a
um a fire in stretford you know it might
not be alteringer more sales punt which
girl Stratford would likely go because
it's in their area but you might have
pumps from my side you know from
Manchester Borough which are nearest so
I I think that's the point of what we're
making in terms of building a stronger
and more resilient fire rescue service
from a response perspective as much as
anything else in that we have a broader
pool of resources to to draw upon
um because they'll come from anywhere
whether it's in stretford alter Ingram
or sale won't be serviced by trafford's
pumps alone and I think having that
additionality even if it is in
Manchester Borough as a location they're
not going to stop at the border and say
we're Manchester resources it's
constantly moving and evolving and I
think it's important to keep that in
mind thank you
I think probably been said now but uh
it's just a couple of points really the
uh
the stuff
uh when I was at the the consultation
sale uh and some of the points that were
coming up you know certainly from the
staff members was that they they didn't
seem too keen on the day uh uh
day model you know and uh you're saying
that this I think subsequent to that
they may have perhaps changed their
minds or moved thinking more about it
that was that was one point because they
did seem concerned that they
particularly weren't keen on that and
the other one thing was the the four
minute
response times uh I mean they're they're
the staff they're the firefighters that
go out and they didn't seem to give much
credibility to that timing uh so I I
just felt there's a bit of a
contradiction in terms of uh how they
how how they didn't feel as confident in
that response uh as opposed to how you
feel you know whether that's you know in
a way of urban aspiration as opposed to
um being able to react in reality do
that in in the ways people have said you
know
yeah thanks for your um
um question I think just taking
um
a couple of points if I can and I think
um the first one is important so myself
and the deputy mayor are attending sale
fire station on the 19th of
um um July
um station staff have written to the
deputy mayor and Michelle separately and
we've got a joint visit and then we're
going to replicate that at
um offerton on the um 20th I think in
terms of
and The credibility of
um the the four minutes and I mean I
don't know whether I'm allowed to ask
questions but I'm gonna go for it I
think
if and it's purely hypothetical if say
or fire station
was in a different part of Salem and you
and and the what weren't the issues of
crossing a major Chuck Trunk Road and
access into it that submerged today
would we be presented with a different
view or would we still be presented with
the same view in terms of the impact on
response times I think that that that's
a point because I think what I'm clear
on I've said it's a non-negotiable
um and that time to time to mobilize is
something that we will be judged on
um and if we can't deliver it then the
fallback position is to maintain the
status
um quote but what we do know
um it is that that four minutes can be
achieved in other parts of Greater
Manchester accepting the point about uh
um urbanized urbanization and I think to
pursue that further I'd need to
discredit what firefighters are doing
um tonight in those
um communities and you know when we
leave you're going to hear from the
Brigade secretary who who is a
firefighter working
um day career in now Dave can speak for
himself so the viability of a day crew
and Duty system is
um solid I think what I'm picking up is
the ability to deliver that in terms of
um
um sale which in many respects
um dominates the um argument and I think
in terms of of Staff in an Ideal World
we would want to maintain as many staff
Who currently work at sale fire station
on a day crew in
um model
the question will be is um can they
reside in what we accept is going to be
a redrawn four minute boundary would the
service be able to explore
um looking at uplifting and enhancing a
relocation package then we will look at
those
um things and as Carlos has said I think
staff who who can't work there I mean it
might be all 28 that don't want to work
the duty system then of course we've got
to displace people because Carlos said I
think when I joined the service the day
querying system in Manchester was broken
pumps were off the Run
who struggled with Recruitment and
Retention
um issues that that you you've you've
cited um and with an excellent working
relationship with the fire brigade Union
we've worked hard to resolve those which
is why we believe that we're able to
propose
the um the growth of the duty system
accepting the point where I I think
there was a view it's been presented as
disingenuous in terms of the language in
the fire cup of review I'm I'm sorry
that that it wasn't intended to be the
case but I understand in terms of how
um that might be um
um that might might be read
um so I hope that that answers the um
you did actually throw a question to us
and I think
um despite the issue that you you've
raised around the a56
the big issue
I think is the four minutes that
Partington have to wait
longer and it's probably the furthest
away area to a fire station already and
that actually you know is is the
argument that most people are actually
putting to us so
I once I've answered your question
um so
that completes this part of the uh of
the session and I'm really grateful for
both of you to come in and and you know
put that case to us and we will
obviously consider all the things that
you have said
um we will be hopefully making
recommendations once we've heard the
um the fbu's side of things so thank you
very much you can stay if you want or
you you may leave
thank you yeah no that's okay well thank
you thank you very much
yeah no problem at all uh thank you
everybody for inviting the fbu this
evening uh my name's Dave Pike I'm the
current fbu Brigade secretary for
greater Manchester uh I've been a
firefighter for 26 years now uh and as
Dave is rightly told you I have been a
day crew firefighter for 18 of them just
over the water at Earlham so I have a
very good knowledge of the day crew
system but in sales is limitations
uh it has positives it has negatives but
you know
he will be under no Illusions as to our
position on this we will not want to see
any reduction in staff numbers and if
our fire station across greater
Manchester the position of the fbu quite
rightly is that we are looking to oppose
this uh
that said uh we our updates already
Let's see we have a really good working
relationship uh with the senior Legion
team great Manchester
I led on the day career in review
uh in Greater Manchester and Davis quite
rightly correcting what he said around
it was broken we literally had at some
of our locations to day crude
firefighters
uh we now have every single fire station
full with waiting lists but that is due
to the renumination package that comes
with it so I don't want to Claudia that
is why it is successful so there is 17.5
uplift for the current renumeration
package for day crew it is in the region
of 37 or within pay uh for working day
cruise so you can see
quite quickly what it is appealing so uh
so for me I've always look to work with
the services best I can uh rather than
saying no traditional fbu Bangla table
saying no we're not doing that see if we
can come up with better solutions for
doing things
uh there's been a lot of talk this
evening around resources and no one's
really
spoke about staff enough in my eyes our
resources are our people
and it's how we use them more
effectively more efficiently and in my
eyes we could quite easily achieve the
Ambitions of the faculty review by using
our people differently with the current
establishment that we've got so uh very
early mass for me on Friday I've worked
out I've been doing a lot of research on
it that we could realize it's extra
pumps keep saying officer as old time
and still realize some savings for PMP
prevention protection which is
which is what they're delivered to
because we are incredibly conscious of
when our fire engines are driving
towards that City Center what that City
Center landscape is looking like and it
is significantly changing on a weekly
monthly basis uh
so I believe there's another alternative
that as I have presented as recently as
Friday I think it's achievable I'm happy
to share if anybody wants to see that
but it's looking at ensuring a
consistency across our day I'll cross
all our stations in terms of
establishment
making sure that everyone has the same
amount of firefighters qualified
firefighters train firefighters
on every single location being
absolutely consistent in how we do that
I think what we've also got to
understand is the service has to quite
rightly has to factor in uh
otherly so I don't know if anyone's
alluded to the ridership factor if
you've ever heard of ridership facts
from fire stations so that builds in we
have a we have a number of staff and
then we look at their leave
we then look at the average thickness
look at how much training need to do and
we look at other absences like maternity
paternity things like that
there's a conscious decision at the
moment that I feel and my other
officials feel that there's a lot of
empathy important training which is
quite right but that shouldn't be at the
expense of emergency response in my eyes
uh it is over factored into the
ridership factor on a fire station and I
think if we can look quite simply at
what does our trainings regime our
schedules look like on fire stations we
can still achieve what we want to
achieve
uh but not have to move sale or offerton
to a day creating model
it doesn't take a genius to go on the
government website to look at fire
incident data uh we are 13 up nationally
already on last year so that's December
2022 uh was the last reported dates with
13 up on our fire rescue service
reported incidents and climate change is
absolutely massive
uh even within great Manchester we can
see the implications of flooding
wildfires are having across greater
Manchester itself if not nationally so
uh for us the immediate response of
firefighters at their locations should
not be won we should be moving away from
uh there's never been a whole time
station move today crewing in the past
it's always been traditionally
well my location they had actually had a
retained fire engine uh next door to it
at the whole time or the day crude one
as it was then but there's never been
this shift from whole time to day
crewing I I completely agree with what
the chief and the rest of CNAs are
trying to achieve here
um when we were in a place not long ago
where we lost six fire engines but I can
see what the chief's trying to achieve
here and trying to get more resource uh
into the places that they're needed but
I do believe there is another way of
looking at this uh in the way that we
use our people across the organization
um some of the data you may not have
seen you may have seen it I mean it to
move day at sale today crewing
you're talking a doubling of the call
data that the busiest day crew in fire
station currently does on actual data so
and that's model data that's not just
what we think is kind of what do we
believe sale are going to be turning out
to throughout the on-call period and all
the challenge around isochromes in four
minutes get it completely
I know that in the middle of the night
when you're turning out your bed at
three o'clock in the morning and it's
frosty you ain't getting into that fire
station four minutes and and my
colleagues live very close
in a semi-rural area so that isochrome
would have to be money for sale
um and whether that's firefighters
turning on bikes
ultimately it's just not achievable uh
as a four minute as it is now I think it
even alluded to being extra Stratford
fire station one of the
isochromes and the fear there is
potentially we'll tell you what if we
can get into sale in four minutes from
Nissa Stratford then
why do we need to sail anymore uh in
Pharmacy she has time and I know that's
not Dave absolutely not
but we don't know potential leaders of
the future austerity so I think it's
important that we look to protect what
we've got currently in the way that it
responds currently by looking at an
approach that's different uh that's one
that's been suggested today
uh there's been no Cannery options so
generally you would get an options paper
we've got this this and this this is
kind of this is it this is what we're
gonna get this is what we're gonna run
with uh so my challenge to the service
has been exactly that is to use our
people better
uh resource them correctly
maybe adjust our training can we train
differently do we have to set them for
fire engine on so many occasions a year
uh and can we do that training
differently so that maintains that
ridership where we can maintain whole
time 24 7 cover both here and both are
offer to
uh
get the challenge around the finances
completely uh you know I've alluded to
some of the the increases in calls but
there's a lot of talk about building
fires but we know that generally
speaking our day-to-day work isn't
building fires it's no traffic
collisions
fully cited on the places for everyone
I can see on a daily basis driving down
the bypass in Earlham the expansion
pattington
we know this capability there for 12 000
homes potentially just in that
connotation that would Place Partington
alone
at the same size of some of our date
crew fire stations as they are now as an
entire town that is just passing to the
loan and the risks that are in them in
an areas as well so uh I say floodings
are up
thighs are up no traffic collisions up
you know 12 000 homes how many cars more
people traveling so the risks are
exponential in terms of increasing all
the time and I think we just need to be
careful in terms of it it does sound
good and we are willing to
kind of work with the service but at
this moment in time with the
establishment we've got we believe it
can be achieved differently uh
that information is sat with Dave and
the SLC uh him as late as three o'clock
today some tweaks in the way the service
currently do things indicate that they
could keep selling offensive as they are
uh I can answer as many questions as you
like about day crew and all about day
crewing but for me it's not a solution
at this moment in time if the service
wants to realize further Assets in the
future uh if we cannot seek extra
funding uh I work quite closely with the
mayor's office maybe Kate green four
times a year uh see only every now and
again so I think the devolved budget
that the mayoral May's got I think
there's conversations there that could
be had between us all uh to look to
expand to return us back to some of the
days where we did our 56 57 58 fire
engines but that does come across but I
don't believe it comes across the middle
of the fire station potentially moving
uh to up to a lower standard of response
join them hours and the comments that
I've heard tonight around the a56
absolutely sale was my first station
posted as an apprentice fire fighter or
a recruit firefighter so it was back
then uh so I know the area fairly well
uh at Earlham we turned out to
Partington incredibly uh often we were
the third pump in attendance in
Partington because we came up with a
high level bridge at Warburton uh
ironically that's been stopped by appeal
now
um so we that third pump from Earlham
coming in which was matching a 10 minute
attendance time because that's what it
was it's all it has been we were coming
into Old Road Wood Lane around that sort
of time so that's that's no longer an
option for us so I think that does need
a bit of pushback because it was
incredibly beneficial for those
communities and that housing estate
around Woodland Road uh because we did
see some significantly serious fires in
them areas so
I mean everything that you said tonight
I was gonna just repeat it's not
probably putting a presentation because
you said everything that we're saying at
the moment but I think we just need to
realize and I've alluded to use our
resources better uh and that's how
people will look after our people
sickness is quite High uh there's a
reason for that I'm not managing people
properly leave get lead Etc so I think
there's a bigger piece here rather than
jumping to the solution of production uh
at certain stations uh I think we can do
things better and that's what I've
provided to the service and hopefully uh
throughout this consultation process and
we will see that play through in the is
an acceptable position to take rather
than moving uh what is in effect and we
know it is it's 50 firefighters we
anticipate that we'll be impacted by
these changes and that's a big that's a
big impact I know what it's what it's
like to see somebody having to move away
from a day crew fire station is huge so
to place 50 firefighters in that
position uh when it could potentially be
avoided uh for me is a better course of
action rather than jumping to let's just
introduce two more DC stations at this
time day cruise stations at this time so
uh I think you kind of got my position
it's the same as yours but I think there
is a solution to still realize the
benefits and I just didn't have to be
explored a bit better so I don't sense
to keep you for another hour and a half
yeah
do you think well
it would be helpful if you got an
alternative and you've given that to the
chief
um it's the only chance that you could
give us yeah yeah that's fine yeah yeah
so the establishment for great
management financing service is 1252
operational staff that's firefighters to
watch manager across the piece uh we
have establishments at one pump stations
of 28 two pump stations of 44 and
Manchester Central is the only fire
station that's got a primary crude
special Appliance that's permanently
crude aerial ladder applied our TTL it's
called now turntable ladder so that's
the only one in Greater Manchester when
I joined I was a sale for a bit in
Salford and we were five four two so you
can see other numbers are dwindled
sulfur moved to four at one point so we
don't we don't permanently crew any of
our specials apart from that one so
you can see how austerity is kicked in
how the numbers have reduced uh and I
can see what Dave and the SLT trying to
achieve
what we want to get back to the days
where
we have we do see our specials primary
crew we do see them turning out on their
own because ultimately if someone wants
an aerial or a platform from say
at the moment Stratford but I know it's
changing but that renders the fire
engine out of use because there's not
enough staff on that fire station now to
crew that fire engine so the Utopia will
be to every every special Appliance crew
to get that a long long way off
well that just kind of alludes to where
we've come over the last 10 to 15 years
in terms of losing firefighters across
group and it's a national pitcher don't
get me wrong we're all you know you only
see what's going on in Scotland for
those that follow on social media that
they ask us there to get rid of 10 fire
engines completely uh London fire
brigade the biggest UK fire rescue
service
seeing up to 30 appliances a day not
available
across the capital city so we are not in
that space you know not even we are not
in that space But we are uh seeing the
the limitations that the courts have
brought over the past 10 to 13 years and
hopefully this is a step forward in
bringing fire engines back because I do
firmly believe that we need to do that
uh the activity levels I don't know uh
Dave's alluded to a lot of prevention
work in the built environment but our
busy City Center fire firefighters are
out a lot at night so an additional 500
in the area areas would benefit them
massively so we are not against what
Dave is proposing quite obviously but we
do believe there's a better way to Win
It
the the
um turntable ladders going to move from
Stratford to Oldham I believe yeah uh in
in the proposals but what C at the used
position on that the data that we've
been presented with does indicate that
the Caged assets that we've got so we've
got five caged assets uh sorry I think
it's six cage assets don't quote me on
that sorry uh and one a quite a new
piece of technology called a high reach
extendable turret vehicle scorpion at
Salford uh the speed of attack that that
offers firefighters and the larger fires
Factory fires things like that uh does
kind of assist with uh resolving big
fires quickly the data around rescues
from cages uh is very very limited and I
think over the past three to five years
there's been on one hand the amount of
occasions where a cage has been used to
rescue somebody uh and one was a time
critical so we you'll still have five
caged assets uh sorry four and three uh
high volume water delivery vehicles
yes yep
um obviously we've got chocolate yeah to
Big stadiums yeah
we've got to move away yeah yeah
are you supporting that it's the data
that we've been given at the moment in
time does show that obviously we would
want to retain as many caged assets as
possible uh
but the main Crux of the what we're
hearing from our members is that they
don't want to see this change from data
from full time to day crewing uh the
accept that probably having more of
these high reach high volume
fire appliances means they're not on
incidents for hours and hours and end
because they're literally just
delivering water a huge rate to conclude
these incidents
um so from a member's perspective we're
not hearing that it's primarily around
the changes to to sale and offer to yeah
are there any questions
okay thanks very much for all of that
and um
I had to well two questions really one
of the things that jumped out at me on
the report was um that the
our service is that they think the only
one in the country looking to expand its
Fleet at the moment which could be
because there is particular local
challenges that mean that's the best
option it could be you know a bold move
that's a good idea but it's also going
against Green nationally so I wondered
what you guys thought about that
obviously you focused very much on the
people resource and some of this is
about expanding the fleet I'm wondering
is that part of what you see the the
alternative plan you see is it about not
expanding the fleet perhaps or what you
think of the plan to expand the fleet
um and also I mean I don't want you to
speak on behalf of the others you've
just left but obviously they've heard
this story they've seen your arguments
they're they're the experts and they're
still not changing their minds I was
wondering if you could comment on why
you think they're not buying into into
your suggestions thanks that's all
thanks for your question so on the
second one literally the proposal that I
presented was presented to them on
Friday as late as this afternoon we were
still looking at it debating it so I
think that's probably not had the time
to reflect on that proposal yet uh so In
fairness to them they're probably not
commented for the right reasons uh
because they haven't had the time to to
divulge the data and what what we're
potentially suggesting uh in terms of
the other question around an increase in
resources yet it's a bit of a weird
scenario to be in as a Trade union
leader in great Manchester in terms of
pushing back slightly on increasing
resources given what I've just described
what's going on uh nationally in other
major Fire and Rescue Services
uh we do
think that the way greater Manchester
deals and his membership deals with
approaching these uh challenges is very
very
good we are probably on one of all the
fire rescue services that has a
Frontline Fleet of fire engines lots
have what's called small incident units
the Clusters fire engines when they
potentially got two three firefighters
on them and we would never Advocate that
and we would always work hard to to push
back on any suggestions to bring them in
to the city uh the thought of
crew of three
possibly two being the first to arrive a
domestic fire faced with a family is no
scenario anybody would want to ever be
in so we welcome the fact that the
service hasn't looked to do that uh and
we welcome the fact that they've
actually looked to introduce further
full-time crude appliances so yeah it
was initially a challenging situation a
conversation to have and that we can if
we were welcoming of it at that time we
didn't really have the data suggest we
could do it an alternative way so it was
a bit of a you know we want we know what
we want to do here
but now we're in a position where we can
look to say oh this can be done but done
differently uh I think we need to push
that uh our proposals through a bit
harder now
um so I will intend to share them with
Kate and with the mayor's office to say
this can be done differently uh
in ultimately trying to realize uh the
additional two fire engines so I
if it came to it then yes we would
probably say forget you two keep selling
offensive full-time because those
response in those communities is more
important than anything else but at this
moment in time we believe we can do both
it's just a different way of doing it
and approaching it
that was my heart like
thank you chair and thank you for coming
to speak to us tonight and you're giving
us some really useful information on
members of committee useful information
I think particularly on the increasing
incidents
um a fire safety is generally improving
but other members have alluded to things
from climate change flash flooding it's
interesting to see incidents are
actually up on last year
um I had a couple of questions which uh
well two of them are specific to sale so
I don't know if you'll be able to help
me out with them but I'll ask I'll I'll
go well I've got three I'll ask all
three questions so I guess the first one
is around you
um what you said was interesting around
the special appliances not having a
dedicated crew so crew go out on those
and I know at sale they've got a
specialist uh foam unit so I just
wondered what how does that translate in
into sale if if the crew have to
um go out on that foam unit what what
options does that leave the fire station
with
um the second question was
um I think Angela new gross asked about
um the nighttime response and if
four or firefighters are turned up and
the fifth one was delayed would be out
as a four or five and I think the answer
was they could go out as a four
um I know that caused a lot of
controversy a couple of years ago when
it was proposed to move from five to
four on each pump so I just wondered if
the fbu had a view on the on the safety
of that if that if that needed to happen
um and the final question was just
around
um
the number of firefighters who are
likely to be able to live within this
four minute the actual form and it drive
into cell fire station
um and asked a question about this as to
how many firefighters are in that area
now and I think I think there's three
operational stuff I'm not sure they're
all Frontline firefighters actually
um do you have any sense of
um and and the chief Forester was quite
candid actually that if if they couldn't
get a 13 firefighters to live within
that four minute Zone then it wouldn't
go ahead
do you have a sense from uh members at
sale or elsewhere as to whether that 13
is achievable because I think members of
the committee were quite skeptical about
it I don't know the fbu overview on that
thank you
thank you so the the current
arrangements for the foam tanker uh will
remain uh what happens currently is that
if that farm tanker is required for the
quite large risks that are in sale in
Carrington uh the drive will be more
than one driver on duty so the driver
will drive the farm tanker and they'll
follow behind in the fire engine uh so
that isn't changed at all really uh and
every single member of staff at sale is
trained in the use of that foam tanker
so uh even if it was Prime recruit with
two the fire engine would still go to
support the crew to set the uh to set
the equipment up so there's no changes
there lots of our day crewing stations
in fact all of our day crewing stations
do have specialist appliances and what
we call double jump uh they planted but
they go together the majority of them
are wild fire fire stations so that
wouldn't change in that respect uh in
terms of the uh fours uh I have been in
this situation personally uh we wouldn't
Advocate responding with less than five
uh but we are we have situations where
we cannot get hold of firefighters
responding so you have a sense that
something that has gone wrong here will
try and contact the individual to see
where they're up to but it would be
incredibly difficult uh for a crew of
four firefighters to not turn out to a
person's reported house fire where
someone is rescuing uh not knowing how
long there's going to be further
detained so yes absolutely five for us
is the minimum but there are situations
and scenarios where you just cannot
stay because I've been there I've been
sat on a fire engine thinking where is
this person where is this person and
it's turned out that the individual has
been delayed or the page is not
activated something along them lines so
we would respond in those circumstances
but for no no less than four we would
always go with four and it would always
have to require an officer to be on the
fire engine as well so so it does happen
I can't say it doesn't happen but it
would but we wouldn't Advocate we would
absolutely want five on every 1.5
station uh responding in terms of
achievability around uh whatever this
isochrome is going to look like uh I
think you've allowed it to its sale as
an expensive area to live in uh even the
remuneration package that comes with
that probably wouldn't get anywhere near
where it needs to be uh firefighters are
quite ingenious when it comes to
finding ways of living somewhere but I
think in a certain area like sale it
just would not be it'd be impossible I
really do feel it's unachievable uh
because it would just be such a tight
isochrome uh given the restrictions on
Match days you've already alluded to uh
how busy that road is uh and having
worked in sale uh I do know how busy it
can be it is it's a semi-urban town
there's no other day crew in station
with an area like this uh with a passing
you know passing traffic like this and
it's only set to get bigger every town
and City and great match is set to get
bigger uh so yeah I would incredibly
challenge the ability for staff to
relocate here and be able to achieve
whatever that isochrome looks like
thank you Chad again um so when I've
spoken to crew members one thing that's
come up every time uh without fail is
the poor quality of the consultation
one crew member that I spoke to
um he said that he felt uh the Brigade
tried to present this stay Korean
proposal as a sort of done deal
um and this is very much a shared view
it's come off every time so are there
lessons to be learned uh about the way
the Brigade engages with members of
staff so that people don't feel let down
or that information isn't left to be
shared by the room or not
yeah thanks we've got yep absolutely uh
I think the way the service has gone
about this uh in quite I won't say
rushed but the way that they've shared
what they chose to share I think the
realization now that what we're seeing
is this can be done differently uh could
have been explored a lot earlier uh I
think there's been one
as staff on station engagement session
uh which is nowhere near enough really
we're talking about changing
firefighters lives on a day-to-day basis
most of our firefighters at sale and
offered and settled within roles they've
been there for a substantial amount of
time they may have child care
Arrangements where they drop the
children off before they got to work on
the way to work etc so none of that has
really been taken into consideration in
this consultation whatsoever uh it
needed to be a lot earlier a lot earlier
a lot more engagement a lot more
questions what does it mean and and
actually explore different ways of
achieving what they want to achieve
so yeah there's huge amount of lessons
to be learned here uh I think early
engagement with the Trade union is
useful and it's played through uh in
other projects similar to our minor and
terrorist attack uh capability now we
were involved from the outset you know
we could give the voice of the people on
the stations to shape what these
projects look like uh unfortunately
that's not happened with this fight club
review and I understand that the
consultation doesn't necessarily start
straight away with the trade unions but
we can alleviate and help assist in
Solutions uh over the period of time if
the engagement was earlier so sorry Chad
in terms of if you'll be you've
mentioned before when uh Geraldine Hogan
spoke uh
if if your proposals are taken forward
and given more time and consideration
with that that will be something that we
see right from the get-go they'll be
there'll be consultation the staff will
be feeding in
um and that's that's the model that we'd
follow yeah I'd like to think so yeah
absolutely I'm waiting for a far more
response uh from the service around what
we are suggesting is a better way of
achieving the outcomes of FICO review uh
so yeah as and when we get a response to
that and we'll feed that into the public
consultation anyway uh
my own I think what I'd like to see is
the pause uh for a moment and say look
let's let's have a look at this if this
can do what the trade unions are saying
it can do then why wouldn't we explore
it a little bit more uh and then it's
either a yes oh it's a no but then I
would seriously question why it's a no
uh because then that leads me to the
position where we are taking out 30
firefighter posts out of the
establishment so that's the 15 on sale
15 Harvard I firmly believe we can do
that without doing that if the service
say no then you've got to question
yourself as to why they want 30 posts
coming out of the system uh so this is
the challenge in the pushback I put to
the service as and when required but as
of yet we're not in a place to say
whether the service is going to kind of
explore the suggestion further that we
put forward
can I ask you directly what do you feel
about you know the the length of time
that it takes from uh sale to party to
um and adding at least four minutes on
onto that time does that put
Partington people in
further Danger
yeah yeah yeah and quite simply yes and
I know they look at the overall response
so house fire department is attended by
it was early altering them in sale uh
it'll now be Earlham sorry sale all
shringham and Stratford uh but if they
never take account of what if they're
not there so what is stretford are on
something else what if ultringham
the length of time worst case scenario
is four minutes of digital time on top
of that and I get the model I'll tell
you differently but that is the reality
I have sat on the back of a fire engine
from sale fire station down that road
all the way into Paddington and it's a
horrible it's a horrible feeling when
you know somebody's
basically trapped inside a house and
you're spending 10 minutes getting there
and I've done it from say from Earlham
as well so it is 10 minutes feels like a
lifetime towards
must feel like an eternity to to those
that are in that situation so to try and
justify extending that period of time
where you are you know trapped for me
we can do things differently then why
don't we
counselor Jamal Jerome
thanks chair I'm a councilor for
altering award
um I think as part of The Proposal they
said there was two main gains one was
the two extra fire engines which Joe
wooden touched upon
um but the other key factor was it was a
redistribution of staff to meet the key
areas and the key factor they said in
this redistribution contribution was the
high rise
flats that are going up in central
Manchester I think um 495 in 2017 693
and 2023 and then there's going to be
way over 900 by 2030. so they're giving
that as the main factor for the
redistribution of the staff I just
wondered how you would counter that
point to say sail and offerton
um you know need to keep their staff and
if they did in your alternative
model
would you not be able to meet that high
rise kind of need so I just wondered
what you say
thanks for your question yeah so the
what my proposal is is that nothing
changes and you bring two additional
fire engines in that is that is the Crux
of the the argument really we can do
this with the establishment that great
Manchester fine excuse currently got
1252 from firefighters it can be
achieved the servers just have to look a
bit differently at how we train our
firefighters so it's the trade-off
between taking firefighters off fire
engines to train which then means we
need extra firefights to backfill do we
need to do that as often which is it's a
balance so for me absolutely response
times emergency response comes before
training because we're having an
automatic time for training so we have
to re-look at how we factor in training
our firefighters in Greater Manchester
to protect the front line to keep them
response times as quick as they possibly
can be uh if the servers choose to go
down the route of we're still going to
take you away from your Frontline job 12
15 16 times a year
then that's the choice they'll have to
be explicit and open with people like
yourselves
in saying that's the choice they're
going to make but I can't sit here
comfortably and say
this should use that as an approach uh
to reducing staff numbers at sale and
offer to because there is a better way
of doing it we can train on stations we
can use locations other than training
centers to train our staff
so I can say I'm waiting for the service
to respond once I've got that response
uh I'm sure you will get sight of that
uh because we do factoring and in order
I'm out of training uh and that's now
being exposed in that we can't deliver
up the service believed it can keep fire
stations like selling officer whole time
but I believe they absolutely can
yeah just some reassurance about the
training that they'll still be receiving
the training they need it just is the
way it's delivered that that would
change yeah yeah I mean we do
I mean I'm I've been in this role now
for 16 months I've got another six seven
months to go to two years of common to
the fifth bu so I'm not used to the
Strategic world all these managers
sitting but I think just pure Maths for
me is quite simple a lot of our
firefighters are tied to to computers
nowadays uh it's what's called my
learning and online learning for me we
do far too much of online we don't do
enough practical uh and I think the
chief can see that as well but a lot of
that practical element of training
doesn't necessarily mean you have to be
taken away from your fire from your
day-to-day role uh I think we can do a
lot more in-house on fire stations using
the facilities we've got across uh the
stations that we've got in great
Manchester to keep them skills up it
doesn't require removing somebody off a
fire engine to do that in my mind uh I
think that's where we need to get two
more than anything but yeah there was a
lot of training
Council Walsh just very quickly that
this you know what they said about the
table the movements from Stratford to
Walden yep you're comfortable with that
can you can you just talk about it
because like you're saying about with
lots of high rises
uh they're actually in Trafford but very
close to castlefield in that area around
Pomona yeah
um it just doesn't seem right to me when
you've got lots of other high risers
being built being built in the city
center
but but you you said to the chair that
you you were comfortable with that with
that table being moved so great man's
fine rescue service has probably got the
best policy on high-rise firefighting in
the country I can say that quite
comfortably uh there's a lots of fire
authorities now looking to expose
firefighters to quite dangerous
situations in high-rise buildings uh so
when we talk about extinguishing fires
in high-rise they're not done from the
outside they're done from the inside and
the taxes that we use are inside these
buildings the way we rescue people in
protected staircases building
construction has come on Leaps and
Bounds completely accepting fell Etc and
the cladding whole different kind of
argument I get there they're still out
there uh but the way we tackle fires in
high rise isn't done from the outside
it's done from the inside using a real
heavy weight of attack which is why we
have five fire engines attending along
with the nearest Aerial Appliance but
generally speaking rescues firefighting
tactics are done within the building
from protect to lobbies and staircases I
think firefighters do see the benefit of
these inordinate amount of water that
can be put on an incident quite quickly
that then releases capability back into
Manchester so it's it's there as much as
can be possible really so it's a fine
line uh but ultimately I don't think
there's as much pushback on that change
as there is to the immediate response
yeah
okay tell me what the questions
and just one on the training uh just
um assuming that kind of the number of
hours delivered in terms of training for
such an important role is is regulated
in some way nationally just in terms of
could you elaborate just a little bit
more on the proposals that you've put in
and how that they might fit kind of you
know National guidelines in terms of
training and or other
um areas operating similar training
models to which you're recommending that
could maybe provide a case study
so as far as I'm aware there are no uh
actual standards on training at all uh
it's down to individual Fire Rescue
Services to determine how they train
their staff and what that training
entails so I uploaded to a lot of it's
online uh a lot of it is higher level
detailed knowledge uh around subjects
that uh in my honest opinion probably
doesn't play through on the incident
ground there's a knowledge that's
required on the incident ground uh maths
equations working out all sorts of this
that and the other that you know
firefighters don't generally need when
they're rocking out to a fire and it's
house on fire they just want to get
there and learn and basically show that
they've got the basics and the
professionalism to deal with that
incident when they arrive so I think
what we're looking at here is let's look
across the piece let's look at all the
training what type of training is being
done can we change the way we do things
uh and modify and
to be frank we're talking about a change
from say 12 days a year to 10 days a
year you know this isn't these ain't not
big numbers to rationalize out and keep
selling offer to
whole time so slight tweaks to the way
we train our Workforce and our staff and
look after our staff uh is for me a
better approach initially in order to
achieve still real attitude additional
pumps and staff to feel valued that
because I do I'm just going back to
council's point there around it's a done
deal a lot of Staff do feel it's a done
deal I think this is what's going to
happen uh and they do honestly believe
that uh and I think the way the
consultations played through is alludes
to that in a certain way as well so I
think it's my role it's everyone in this
room's role to to challenge and to push
back and where there is other
Alternatives that are there and
available then we explore them in as
much detail as possible uh and ask for
explanations as to why the service
doesn't feel that that's an appropriate
way to go about things so uh so yeah I
think the training is a massive it's a
huge thing and as we move through
there's potential for Graham Manchester
to be one of the first UK Fire and
Rescue Services to step back into the
Emergency Medical Response space so we
have to factor that in as well in these
station areas where we will potentially
be co-responding in the future with our
colleagues in mwas so that core volume
will go up so there's lots and lots of
things at play here uh in terms of
immediate response and I don't think we
should ever move away from what is best
practice without clear concise
well-reasoned rationale and I think what
we've got potentially here is a solution
to to achieve what Dave wants to achieve
and also maintain the whole time at sale
and offer to so if we were to recommend
and pause
you know in in in the uh consultation
um to look at another alternative that
have been put forward towards by by
yourself
um
would you be
okay with that if we if we do decide
that I'm not saying that we do this our
example
um I would absolutely welcome that yeah
I think you know again it's very last
minute for me to come I didn't get to
the offerton uh consultation I couldn't
make that one but I didn't have I hadn't
done the research and then the workings
out around that at the time but for me
yeah absolutely if there's a
recommendation to pause and explore this
further then that would really welcome
that here okay
um this is no other questions
um can I thank you very much for coming
along and we will have our deliberations
um following this meeting and uh I'm
really grateful for you thanks again
foreign
of a safe journey home
right
um
well we've we've heard you know the
plans being put forward to us
um for for from the chief
and I think there has been a lot of
pushing back from the members in terms
of the plans
um and I think you know we need to
look now and we've heard obviously the
Trade union side to it
um
I think we need to
try to pull together you know some
bullet points of what we actually feel
um that we'd want to put to the leader
and the executive
and Council
um so Barry you you wanted to uh yeah
thank you chair I was quite surprised
the first the first alternative proposal
first I've heard of any alternative
proposal was from the
the fbu rep tonight so
um I think a detailed analysis of the
plan before us will be gone to some
extends daily meaningless until we've
seen the alternative because he was very
he was very he was very certain that his
plan gave the cost savings
uh which allowed to be two extra pumps
and didn't reduce the any of the
response times so I think if the central
thing would be to have a pause to see
the Alternatives and then do the details
analysis then thanks chair
yeah I mean I think
I think also we we probably
need to we we need to express
what has been actually said in this
meeting and back by members which
basically
um I think the the key point is that
four minutes isn't it I think we've all
talked about that four minutes and the
uh and the dangers that come out of that
for the people that you know we
represent and you know I think that's
for me anyway that that's a side that we
should be on is the people that we
represent and uh I know because people
have told me the the part into meeting
there was about 40 residents there and
they were very clear that they did not
want this change to happen
and I think we need to reflect that in
in our response and then other
you know other issues that we might want
to raise
I think it's uh
I'm gonna put my hand up here but I'm
not realized just how poor
the fire and rescue coverage for
Partington is
that just never occurred to me before
yeah you go beyond the sale fire station
and it's heavy dragons literally because
we don't need to put the fires out
um to actually reduce and there's no
doubt at all that this is a reduction in
service to reduce that service out of
the sale station
without allowing
for something in Partington
this is horrifying
absolutely they've even lost the Earlham
option for response because of Peel
saying we can't have your big nasty
noisy engines on our Bridge
it's the the process is crazy it's
it's a paper exercise and I'm vaguely
suspicious about anything that requires
the invention of a new word
and that's isochrome
hands up anybody who's ever heard that
word before
you did
I'm sorry get a life
I see I'm just grossly suspicious
foreign
thank you chair I have a few questions
about procedure so in terms of
recommending a pause
um obviously that wasn't suggested
earlier in the meetings we haven't heard
the fire chiefs thoughts on that
um I wonder in terms of obviously his
argument is that this will make it safer
overall so is there a risk that by
proposing a pause we're actually making
things more dangerous so it's a question
about procedure that really why did we
have these two people not all in the
same room at the same time why haven't
we had an opportunity to put this
proposal back to the fire chief I know
they're busy people but
um and I don't know if or I hadn't
certainly come into this meeting there
was nothing in any of the notes
circulated saying that we would discuss
a pause so this isn't something that we
were able to prepare thoughts on or ask
um you know experts about so that was
one procedural question and the other
procedural question was I was just
curious is we've never had an
extraordinary meeting of scrutiny since
I've been on the committee before I see
on the Constitution there are a number
of mechanisms by which one can be called
and I was interested to know what
mechanism has been used this time so two
sort of procedural questions really and
and then the third question about really
what will be the impacts if the fire
chief is correct and this is a safer way
to go and we ask for a pause and then
there are some some concerns there thank
you I think with regard to the
pause a tastes the first time that we've
heard about it I'm not saying that
that's what we do
um we're having a discussion of what we
actually do I think the extraordinary
um meeting that we're
holding is the the public interests that
um and the fire
um you know the the fire uh
surface itself you know is asking for us
to
um and other organizations and other
councils to to comment and I decided as
chair that it would be an extraordinary
meeting okay so thank you I was also
going to say um I think it was also seen
as a very large issue which if it was to
come up in a standard meeting wouldn't
be given the adequate time it requires
and as you can see at the time the meat
has been taken that was a correct
decision okay thank you so it was by the
chairs request that was that was the
answer to my question thank you
ah thank you chair yeah one of the
reason suggesting a pause is that if
somebody comes up with a plan which
seems to be an alternative to the plan
put before us
to not consider it would be somewhat
remiss and exactly to have the kind of
more than one option in front of us at
which we were asking we would ask the
views of both the the fbu and the um and
the fire service themselves on the
different doctors in front so to rerun
this meeting basically except we'd have
more than one plan in front of us thank
you chair
well I think we just heard language
matters a moment ago I don't see any
consensuses in this room for the plan
it's clearly
distressing to those working there and
to the residents why are we suggesting a
pause I've spoken to my colleagues I
believe we should be rejecting the
proposals and looking for an alternative
which suits the constraints of time
money and resources which apparently
we're being presented with in due course
and like I say language matters and
people have felt inadequately consulted
with both on the side of the staff and
the residents so to say it's a pause
is merely an elongation in time before
we eventually do it anyway and that is
not the consensus of this room by any
stretch so I think we need to look at
rejecting it
but it was on the you know it was a
discussion that we had with the trade
unions and it was something that I
thought that we can discuss without the
Trade union or the leadership of the
fire service
oh well
yeah thanks just to elaborate on what um
Council of frassas said I support that
book kindly not in the same strong
manner that he put forward I think the
consensus is that we do reject the
proposals for far sale fire station in
the first instance and we've been given
an alternative here which
um would be sensible to look at but our
stance should be that we reject the
proposals for sale fire station and if
alternatives are available we can
explore them yeah
yes you can
um I think that a lot of this I think
Council owners you summed it up in one
when you said that it felt rushed the
consultation I think that that should be
what the
um committee kind of goes back
um it seems that the data hasn't been
looked at well enough
um I think that when they're looking at
um the responses to Partington they
should be able to see where the fire
engines are coming from
um that are responding within those
times so when they say like oil get
picked up by other parts of the system
the system is going to be pretty much
the same the rest of it so if they see
if they can like say well if you took
sale out of here
then we could say that there would have
been an additional response time of like
two minutes to puffington in that
instance they should be able to look at
all this data if they know we're all
their uh things are they should be able
to then uh say well if you took sale out
at this point in time I added extra four
minutes then this would have been the
response time they should be able to
calculate it all up so I think
there's so many areas where they could
have done further uh work on it the fact
that they hadn't put forward any other
proposal seems to say that they haven't
done enough looking at possible
Alternatives so I think that you could
reject it on the first principle uh
First Look saying that you feel that
it's rushed and not saying that you've
reject it all outright but that you feel
that further assurances in certain areas
need to be given before you would be
happy to accept those proposals
um going through and like look at it
like that kind of I mean I'm I'm quite
happy to to reject the proposals and
give reasons why we'd reject the
proposals because it it's not been
convincing enough for for me and I think
other members
um and
you know at the end of it we could
actually say you know if if
you you need other options that doesn't
require the day crewing and taking it so
so there's ways that we can actually do
that Jill first and then you both
um yeah I agree with Alex I think um the
four minute response doesn't seem
feasible and I think there's not enough
we won't give any enough information to
to justify what why it's happening so I
think for those reasons it's not a pause
we're looking for we're rejecting that
and we would like to see other
Alternatives from all parties yeah yeah
thank you all right
thank you chair you're right counselor
language doesn't matter so um yeah I
think I'll change my position too
the consensus in the room to reject the
proposals as they now stand for all the
reasons which Alex went into and that
allows us then time to see the
alternative proposals from the uh from
the fbu yeah thank you yeah
I think we're coming to a consensus
really on on what we do
um
and I think if we can
put it together
in writing and send it to the committee
members
[Music]
Dave Ross away he didn't look like a
confident man didn't he came in here he
looked worried to death he didn't search
me being confident and being able to
take on all allcomers with his with the
question he's like he's trying to sell
something he's not quite believing
himself you know
oh you know I
I don't think we should sort of discuss
that I think he had a hard time
impartington to be honest
right so is everybody happy with that
stunts and then we will try and do it in
a kind of
um
bullets
way you know so so that we've got all
you know all the stuff that we are not
happy with
um and we can't support it as it stands
yeah okay
right
I will do that
um
I understand that the leaders
put in a response together and he would
like to have it as soon as
possible
um
yeah are you saying you can't hear me
I'm sorry
um I've spoken to the leader and the
lead has been asked to put a response
together and I think he's doing that
tomorrow
um and alongside of that
we could give her
the leader our response
if that's okay with everybody yeah
okay so if everybody's happy I will
conclude the meeting and have a safe
journey home and have a good rest of the
evening and can I thank you all for your
patience as well because it's a
a quite a long meeting
and of course it was
on about right